[Musique]
bonjour Cédric Perin bonjour merci de
nous accompagner pour la première
demi-heure de cette émission je rappelle
que vous êtes sénateur les républicains
du Territoire de Belfort et président de
la commission des Affaires étrangère de
la défense et des forces armées du Sénat
vous présidez également la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement une
première question d'actualité Cédric
Perin qui concerne la colère agricole la
grogne des agriculteurs contre les
normes environnemental Gabriel Atal a
promis des annonces rapides cette
semaine qu'est-ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement pour répondre à cette
colère des agriculteurs écoutez je crois
d'abord qu'on doit euh se souvenir de ce
que nous devons à nos agriculteurs et
sous le général de Gaulle la
souveraineté puisque c'est un des sujets
de ma commission la souveraineté
alimentaire c'était la capacité de
j'allais dire de de d'être maître de son
destin aujourd'hui on voit bien que les
différentes évolutions de notre système
européen agricole ont fait que nous ne
sommes plus indépendants et je crois que
les normes que nous imposons aux
agriculteurs comme d'ailleurs les normes
que nous imposons à nos maères et et
autres commencent à fatiguer tout le
monde et et ne sont plus acceptables
d'un point de vue j'allais dire euh euh
du développement de cette agriculture je
prends un exemple très concret qui
parlera à tout le monde dans mon dans ma
région en franchectée pour la seule
franche comptée c'est 1,3 million
d'hectares de terr qui vont être
supprimé en terre agricole parce que les
zones humides vont être définies et
cetera donc je crois qu'ilà un moment
donné il faut que les les directions des
territoires dans nos département fasse
preuve euh j'allais dire de de de
bienveillance donc faut arrêter avec
normes écologiqu je dis pas qu'il faut
arrêter avec les normes écologiques je
pense que nous sommes très vertueux en
la matière que depuis des années et des
années les agriculteurs font des efforts
très importants et que aujourd'hui ils
ont besoin aussi de retrouver j'allais
dire le fruit de leur travail euh parce
que à force de ne pas rémunérer un
certain nombre de production on va finir
par avoir des des productions sur des
TER agricole qui ne sont plus voués à
l'agriculture et qui ne sont plus voués
à à nourrir la population or l'objectif
de l'agriculture c'est de nourrir les
populations donc il y a besoin de se
souvenir de ce que nous leur devons et
nous devons je je pense très
contrairement très concrètement faire
des efforts en la matière alors Cédric
Perin on va consacrer une large part de
cet entretien à la guerre en Ukraine on
accueillera dans quelques minutes notre
reporter Fabien reker qui est allé à
Kiev en décembre pour prendre le pou
d'une société ukrainienne fatiguée vous
y étiez on est voilà pour prendre le pou
d'une société ukrainienne fatigué par ce
conflit d'abord sur le plan militaire
est-ce que vous pensez que l'Ukraine
peut encore gagner ce conflit qui
s'enlise depuis des mois avec un échec
finalement d'une contreofensive
contreoffensive
ukrainienne écoutez d'abord nous sommes
allés en Ukraine pour une raison
essentielle c'est que il est important
que nous remettions ce sujet j'allais
dire sur le haut de la pile les
événements qui se sont déroulés en
Israël au début du mois d'octobre le 7
octobre très précisément on fait qu'une
actualité en chassant une autre le sujet
israélien est un peu passé au second
plan le sujet ukrainien pardon est un
peu passé au second plan or il était
important de rappeler à chacune et
chacun que les Ukrainiens se battent
pour nous également c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui les sacrifices qu'ils
font ils les font pour l'ensemble de
l'Europe et il est important donc que la
France soit un allié exemplaire de
l'Ukraine comme elle est elle doit être
un allié exemplaire de l'OTAN et donc
qu'elle fournisse du matériel et euh
tout ce qui sera nécessaire avec les
alliés autres alliés évidemment pour
faire en sorte que les Ukrainiens
puissent faire face à à à l'ennemi russe
or il est bien évident aujourd'hui lui
que la dissymétrie entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine d'un point de vue humain
notamment puisque on a avoué on a dit
que sur dans le rapport que nous avons
commis suite à notre visite en Ukraine
près de 30000 soldats euh russes étaient
acheminés sur le front tous les mois
pour remplacer celles et ceux qui
étaient en poste
euh ce n'est pas forcément vrai du côté
ukrainien parce que le renouvellement
n'est pas aussi simple euh d'un point de
vue j'allais dire des du point de vue
des armes également il y a une forte
demande des Ukrainiens de pouvoir
obtenir des munitions et du matériel qui
leur permettent de faire face donc je
suis pas à dire ce qu'ils vont gagner ou
qu'ils ne gagneront pas mais en tout cas
ce qui est certain c'est que si nous ne
les aidont pas massivement ils ne
gagneront pas et justement Emmanuel
Macron a annoncé une nouvelle aide
militaire à l'Ukraine avec six canons
César 40 missiles scalpe vous euh saluez
cet cet engagement renforcé de la France
dans l'armement de l'armée ukrainienne
mais tout ce qui va tout ce qui va dans
le sens d'un renforcement de l'armée
ukrainienne est une bonne nouvelle donc
les nouvelles les les annonces qui ont
été faites par le Président de la
République sont des annonces qui doivent
être prises comme des annonces très
positives la question c'est est-ce que
nous pouvons faire plus parce que nous
devons le faire et justement dans ces
vux aux armées Emmanuel Macron a parlé
finalement d'une entrée pour la France
dans une économie de guerre est-ce que
c'est souhaitable pour notre pays
écoutez moi je pense que de ce point de
vue-là les B ont un sens ça fait
maintenant plus d'un an que le Président
de la République le Gouvernement nous
parle d'économie de guerre pourquoi pas
je pense que l'objectif est louable
l'objectif c'est d'accélérer les
productions de diminuer les délais de
livraison et donc de de j'allais dire de
d'être plus efficient euh sauf que dans
une économie de guerre et c'est pour ça
que je dis que les mot ont un sens dans
une économie de guerre comme celle que
nous avons connu malheureusement après
la 2uxème guerre mondiale c'était 28 %
après la 2ème guerre mondiale du PIB qui
était consacré à la défense c'était 5 %
dans les années 60 c'est difficilement
aujourd'hui moins de 2 % c'était à
l'époque des réquisitions de de matériel
des réquisitions d'hommes des
réquisitions d'entreprise ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui donc les mots ont
un sens une une économie de guerre c'est
des moyen pour produire plus vite pour
produire davantage aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes pas en guerre et donc dire que
nous sommes dans une économie de guerre
pour moi c'est de la comme je ne cesse
de le dire il faut que nous soyons clair
en revanche évidemment les objectifs
sont louables nous sommes dans une
période où si nous voulons la paix nous
devons préparer la guerre c'est un peu
un un proverbe qui me semble approprié
et donc si nous voulons gagner la paix
il faut que nous soyons en capacité d'
de l'imposer et pour l'imposer il faut
que nous ayons des matériels
suffisamment en suffisamment grand
nombre pour pouvoir être dissuasif
vis-à-vis de potentiels adversaires donc
il faut qu'on met évidemment les moyens
et puis nous devons aussi être des
alliés exemplaires c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure et des alliés
exemplaires ce sont des alliés qui sont
en capacité d'aider euh leur leur leur
protéger leurs alliés en leur
fournissant du matériel or aujourd'hui
nous le faisons mais dans des dans des
dans des proportions relativement
limitées alors vous êtes allé à Kiev en
décembre nos reporters vous ont suivi et
en on profité pour rencontrer des
Ukrainiens qui ont été blessés on
accueille tout de suite notre notre
reporter Fabien
[Musique]
Réard bonjour Fabien bonjour Alex
bonjour Cédric Plérin bonjour alors vous
êtes allé en à Kiev en décembre
racontez-nous un peu ce qui vous avez
rencontré notamment des des blessés du
du conflit alors donc nous étions à Kief
avec Jonathan dupriaz en décembre
dernier donc la capitale a plus de 600
km du front la ville est régulièrement
la cible des bombardements russes des
attaques de drones mais Kief et sa
région sont assez efficacement défendus
protégé par la défense anti-aérienne si
bien que quand on se déplace dans la
ville et bien on peut être gagné par eux
une impression de normalité les gens
VAAC à leurs occupations ils occupent
les bares les restaurants et pourtant la
guerre y est bien présente et pour s'en
rendre compte il suffit par exemple de
pousser la porte de ce centre de
rééducation pour amputé de guerre que
nous avons visité je ne sais pas si on
le voit là sur les images de Jonathan
dupriz on le voit les autorités de santé
ukrainiennes ont communiqué cet été un
chiffre de de 50000 soldats amputés
depuis février 2022 nous avons rencontré
l'un d'entre eux il s'appelle viacheslaf
il a 57 ans il a été blessé le le 10
septembre dernier à robotigier c'est un
village dans la région de zaporidja un
village qui venait d'être libéré par
l'armée ukrainienne et viacheslaf y
intervenait avec son unité de déminage
il nous
raconte c'était un dimanche matin à
l'aube quand le soleil s'est levé nous
avions terminé notre travail nous étions
en train de sortir de la zone de danger
et c'est un sniper qui m'a
eu tout d'un coup Bou je me suis demandé
est-ce que j'ai marché sur une mine
c'est impossible c'était un chemin sûr
que nous venions d'emprunter ça ne
pouvait pas arriver mais je tombe et je
vois que ma jambe n'est plus
là alors dans ce centre de rééducation
avant la guerre on s'occupait surtout
d'amputer civil de victime d'accident de
la route ou de personnes atteintes du
diabète mais depuis tout a changé et
c'est Maria Yenko qui nous le raconte
elle est médecin
rééducateur depuis 2 ans nous avons
affaire à des cas plus compliqués dû à
l'explosion des mines avec des
polytraumatismes il s'agit parfois de
double amputation et le plus souvent ce
sont de jeunes
patients alors le jour où nous avons
filmé Vial que on a que l'on a vu tout à
l'heure cela faisait seulement une
semaine qu'il s'entraînait à marcher
avec sa sa nouvelle prothèse qui est en
fait une prothèse provisoire le temps
que sa prothèse définitive soit
fabriquée et c'est un prothésiste qui
s'en charge sur place dans une petite
pièce qui ressemble un peu à un atelier
de sculpture là aussi je sais pas si on
voit les images de de Jonathan du prièz
ce monsieur il s'appelle volodimir
Fedorov il travaille à la main pour
concevoir avec du platre ses prothèses
surmesure pour chaque patient il a 40
ans de métier il est à l'aube de la
retraite et il ne s'attendait pas en fin
de carrière à devoir remettre les
Bouchet
doubles nous travaillons intensément
quand j'arrive chez moi le soir je tombe
de
fatigue à la maison tout est en désordre
pas le temps de faire quoi que ce
soit nous sommes fatigués mais nous
devons continuer nous n'avons pas le
choix alors Fabien la fatigue que décrit
cet ukrainien c'est un peu la fatigue de
toute la société ukrainienne en effet
Alex c'est à l'image de de volodimir
Fedorov c'est un peu toute la société
qui qui commence à montrer des signes
d'épuisement dans le centre de Kief nous
nous sommes rendus devant le mur des
héros ce mur affiche les portraits de
soldats qui sont tombés au front depuis
le début de la guerre dans le donbas en
en 2014 alors combien sont-ils
exactement on ne sait pas puisque les
autorités ukrainiennes ne communiquent
pas de chiffre officiel devant ce mur en
tout cas nous avons rencontré une jeune
femme de 28 ans elle s'appelle Maria
deremchou
elle a déjà perdu deux de ses cousins au
front elle était venue se recueillir
lorsque nous l'avons
interrogé on a le sentiment que ce mur
comme cette guerre ne s'arrête jamais
que c'est sansf que ces morts sont
innombrables on ressent une très grande
peine mais en même temps en regardant
tout ça tu dis que tu n'as pas le droit
de t'arrêter que tu dois tenir face à
tout ce que traverse notre pays
alors vous l'entendez beaucoup de
tristesse une grande lassitude aussi
mais malgré tout une volonté féroce de
ne pas baisser les bras parmi toutes les
personnes que nous avons interrogé pour
ce reportage donc tourner on le rappelle
fin décembre à Kiev pas une seule ne
nous a dit envisager une autre issue que
la victoire de l'Ukraine contre la
Russie de Vladimir Poutine et ce malgré
la situation périlleuse dans laquelle se
trouve le pays sur le plan militaire
alors que débute une 3ème année de
guerre Cédric Perin est-ce que la
société ukrainienne peut tenir ind
dééfiniment dans ce
conflit écoutez je je d'abord je
voudrais vous féliciter pour votre
reportage parce que il est évidemment il
permet de mettre j'allais dire une image
sur la réalité de la guerre et je crois
que malheureusement les gens quand on
vit la guerre à distance comme nous la
vivons depuis Paris oublie la réalité de
la guerre au vie oublie le concret de la
guerre le concret de la guerre c'est ce
qu'on disait un manque de munition mais
ce sont aussi des morts des personnes
qui sont amputées qui vivront le reste
de leur vie avec ce stigmate de de la
guerre et je crois qu'il faut que nous
nous nous prenions conscience en tout
cas de la capacité des Ukrainiens à être
résilient enfin c'est ce qui m'a quand
même largement marqué et et ce qui me ce
qui me marque aussi dans ces chez ces
gens qui sont menacés ou qui sont en
guerre c'est leur détermination et et je
fais un parallèle pour me pardonnerz
cette ce parallèle mais j'ai reçu la
semaine dernière la la présidente du
parle chipriote euh qui eux aussi sont
menacés dans une certaine mesure et je
trouve et j'en reçois d'autres et je
pourrais citer d'autres exemples je
trouve que ces gens qui sont menacés
sont déterminés et c'est ce qui me
marque le plus et donc évidemment la
lassitude je je comparais parfois on l'a
fait d'ailleurs pendant le voyage l'état
de de de de l'Ukraine à à à la France de
la de la Première Guerre mondiale 1916
c'est l'usure c'est la c'est c'est la
lassitude c'est la difficulté c'est
l'absence d'aide et je crois qu'on est
dans un un tournant de cette guerre en
Ukraine aujourd'hui ù où ça peut
basculer d'un côté comme d'un autre et
donc il ont besoin impérativement d'une
aide occidentale d'une aide de leurs
alliés qui soi massive et l'objet de
notre visite c'était aussi de remettre
ce sujet sur le haut de la pile je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure mais il faut qu'on
fasse attention à à ces actualités qui
en chassent une autre il y a des
actualités qui sont quand même qui
nécessitent quand même qu'on continue
d'en parler largement alors les
Ukrainiens on ont besoin d'une aide
européenne on a parlé de l'aide
militaire il faut aussi une aide
sanitaire et peut-être à plus long terme
une aide de la France de l'Europe dans
la reconstruction de ce pays mais bien
sûr aujourd'hui on est dans une aide
militaire mais quand je parle de
résilience il y a quelque chose qui m'a
marqué en Ukraine quand vous quand vous
êtes à Kief finalement si vous ne sortez
pas de Kief vous allez très loin vous
voyez aucun stigmate de la guerre en
fait dès qu'il y a quelque chose d'abîmé
ils vont le reconstruire immédiatement
pour montrer qu'ils sont capables de de
rebondir je crois que nous aurons besoin
évidemment de les accompagner nous nous
Français évidemment mais l'ensemble des
pays européens et je pense que ceux qui
seront présents aujourd'hui en Ukraine
et qui qui seront en tout cas force de
de de d'aide pour les Ukrainiens seront
ceux qui seront les les mieux à mêmes à
l'issue en tout cas du du conflit de de
les aider donc il faut qu'on soit
présent évidemment pour toutes ces
raisons merci beaucoup Fabien pour votre
intervention et pour nous avoir
présenter votre reportage je le rappelle
son titre Ukraine la guerre d'usure et
il est à voir sur le site internet
publicsenat.fr merci beaucoup Merci à
VOUS céric Perin on va parler de la
guerre d'Israël contre le Hamas
Sébastien le corn était
hier à té Aviv le ministre des Armées
français il a rencontré les autorités
israéliennes Benjamin netanahou et il a
évoqué la livraison de médicaments par
la France et le Qatar pour les otages du
Hamas il espère que cette livraison va
se faire si elle est réalisée ce sera
une petite avancée pour la survie des
otages bah je crois qu'on est exactement
dans la même situation que l'Ukraine
c'est-à-dire que tout doit être mis en
œuvre pour aider au maximum les otages
en espérant évidemment que l'aide
humanitaire que le droit humanitaire de
la guerre soit respecté et que et que
l'aide humanitaire et que l'aide en
matière de médicament parvienne
jusqu'aux otages ça c'est un sujet
puisque je rappelle qu'on les amène au
Qatar que les Qatar les amène en gros en
Égypte et qu'ensuite ils sont mis à
disposition des Israéliens et et du on
l'espère du Hamas pour pouvoir être
acheminé auprès des otages donc on
l'espère évidemment c'est quand même
parfois des pathologies qui doivent être
soigné et et des gens qui doivent être
soutenus donc il faut é mettre le
souhait évidemment que que cette aide
parvienne à destination alors sur cet
aspect sanitaire de cette guerre depuis
2 mois le porte hélicoptère français le
dixmud apporte de l'aide humanitaire
dans la bande de Gaza il doit lever
l'encre à la fin de la semaine est-ce
que cela veut dire que l'aide
humanitaire française va
baisser écoutez non je il y a aucune
raison qu'elle baisse l'aide humanitaire
se déroulera peut-être d'une manière
différents d'autres moyens seront mis à
disposition mais l'aide humanitaire n'a
aucune raison de de française en tout
cas n'a aucune raison de baisser dans un
moment où il y en a de plus en plus
besoin est-ce que vous appelez un cesser
le feu à Gaza ou alors vous défendez et
bien l'idée qu'Israël a la nécessité de
continuer les les bombardements pour
éradiquer le Hamas écoutez euh l'an
derni en 2022 le la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense des
forces armées que je préside a fait un
rapport sur Israël et mes collègues avec
le président de l'époque le président
Cambon se sont rendus en Israël ils sont
allés dans la bande de Gaza c'est sans
doute une des dernières délégations qui
sera d'ailleurs allé dans la bande de
Gaza il ils ont constaté quelque chose
d'ailleurs c'est dans le rapport d'assez
troublant c'est que les Israéliens
considéraient que euh le problème
palestinien a été réglé et qu'il pouvait
continuer finalement la colonisation la
sis-jordanie notamment
euh sans sans finalement ne rien donner
au au Palestiniens aujourd'hui
malheureusement cette terrible attaque
euh du du du du Hamas euh c'est horrible
l'attaque du Hamas a eu lieu le 7
octobre est on voit chaque jour un peu
plus la paix s'éloignée sauf que nous
avons très clairement dit que la seule
solution c'était la solution à deux
états nous l'avons écrit l'an dernier et
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation où un allié un ami doit
pouvoir être doit pouvoir dire à à à ses
amis en amis justement et donc aux
israélien que la situation n'est plus
tenable euh il faut à un moment donné
trouver une solution à une sore de
sortie par le haut euh on a bien
conscience évidemment que les les les
les les les les actes abjects qui ont
été commis par les nombre du Hamas en
octobre devait être ne pouvait pas
rester en tout cas sans sans réponse
mais aujourd'hui ce que nous souhaitons
évidemment c'est une solution de paix je
pense que tout un chacun aujourd'hui ne
peut souhaiter que cela donc nous
souhaitons évid pourir cette pil faut
faire pression sur Israël on rappelle
que l'un européenne est un partenaire
commercial important d'Israël est-ce
qu'à un moment et bien il faut durcir un
petit peu le ton pour obtenir ce cesser
le feu je pense qu'il faut mettre les
moyens pour faire comprendre aujourd'hui
à Benjamin netanahou et et à son
gouvernement finement que
euh seul la paix peut peut permettre en
tout cas de trouver euh de de d'être
enfin doit doit être trouvé dans ce dans
ce conflit entre Israël et et le Hamas
et qu'il n'y a pas d'autres solution
aujourd'hui les risques de d'embrasement
de la région sont importants chacun je
pense de manière diplomatique joue son
rôle pour essayer de faire en sorte de
de de de de jouer la
déconflictualisation je sais pas si ça
se dit comme ça mais
euh mais mais on a un seul objectif
c'est là évidemment et il faut éviter
aussi toutes ces toutes ces ces ces ces
effets d'annonce qui consistent pour
certains ministres parfois à dire nous
allons continuer la colonisation nous
allons je crois que les provocations
c'est pas le moment et que il faut
évidemment mettre sur la table les
moyens de
discussion a ch et que tout le monde
apèisese les choses Cédric Perin on va
dire un mot du travail de la commission
des affaires étrangères du Sénat à venir
dans les prochains mois vous vous allez
lancer une mission d'information sur le
groupe atthos ce géon informatique
français qui est en place d'être racheté
par le milliardaire tchèque Daniel
kretinski en quoi ce rachat est un
problème j'ai j'ai soulevé le problème
Athos le 2 août dernier le 2 août 2023
dans une tribune qui a été Cigné par 82
de mes collègues au moment où
effectivement le groupe atthos risquait
d'être vendu à des mains étrangères pour
une raison assez simple c'est que Athos
est un acteur de la souveraineté
française en matière de dissuision
nucléaire notamment avec un avec un un
système qui s'appelle enfin qui que sont
des super calculateurs qui ont pour
vocation à simuler des essais nucléaires
c'est-à-dire que depuis 96 date d'arrêt
des essais nucléaires euh toutes les
informations qui ont été euh euh
j'allais dire euh récupéré suite aux ESS
nucléaires euh ont été mises dans un
gros ordinateur si je résume les choses
et aujourd'hui ces gros ordinateurs qui
sont des super calculateurs qui sont
détenu par Atos permettent de simuler
des essas nucléaires et donc ils sont
évidemment un des outils essentiels de
la de l'indépendance française et entre
autres il y en a d'autres aussi le cyber
aussi est est un outil par largement
développé par Atos et qu'il maîtrise
largement et donc ce que nous ne
souhaitons pas c'est que ces compétences
soient prises en compte par des
puissances étrangères et donc nous avons
dès le mois d'août dernier avec 82 de
mes collègues lancé un appel au
gouvernement et et et à l'état pour dire
que il y avait urgence à être à faire
preuve de prudence sur ce dossier les
choses ont bougé puisque tout a été
quelque peu bloqué et puis et puis
aujourd'hui on essaie de de de trouver
les solutions mais atos est dans une
situation économique très difficile et
donc nous sommes très prudents dans la
manière dont nous abordons les choses
mais en tout cas avec la commission des
affaires économiques euh et la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forcesam nous allons
faire une mission commune qui doit
commencer son travail très prochainement
tout au tout début du mois de février
pour travailler sur cette question
d'Atos et comprendre ce qui s'est passé
et nous n'excluons pas avec Dominique
estr Sasson la présidente de la
commission des affaires économiques si
toutefois euh les personnes que nous
souhaitons rencontrer n'étaient pas
suffisamment compréhensives nous
n'excluons pas de transformer cette
mission d'information en commission
d'enquête afin de pouvoir aller jusqu'au
bout des demandes que nous faisons et
que nous formulons à la société mais
aussi à l'état français et quelle
personne vous souhaitez auditionner il y
aura beaucoup de gens beaucoup de gens
qui ont à un moment ou à un autre été
j'allais dire dans le dans le jeu ou
dans le dans le dans dans le dans le
dans le destin d'Atos il a il y a une
multitude de de personnes qui voulait
que les directeurs passent les un A les
autres se succède il y a Daniel krtinski
fera partie des personnes auditionnées
écoutez je je ne ferai pas partie de la
commission les rapporteurs vont être
désignés par la commission demain ils
l'ont été par la Commission d'
affffaires éco je crois la semaine
dernière ce sera à eux de décider de qui
ils souhaitent auditionner mais en tout
cas ce que nous souhaitons c'est mettre
en œuvre un rapport qui permette de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé chez Atos
dernière question politique Cédric Perin
sur les élections européennes François
Xavier bamier a été désigné tête de
liste les républicains pour la campagne
c'est le bon choix pour la droite
écoutez moi j'en suis très heureux parce
que Fran fr vous aviez êt un ami d'abord
et parce que je pense que c'est la bonne
personne au bon endroit c'est quelqu'un
euh qui réfléchit qui qui j'allais dire
qui qui qui imagine en tout cas des
solutions et qui a parfaitement
conscience des difficultés que nous
rencontrons avec avec l'Europe et donc
qui va pouvoir s'il est suffisamment
entendu euh parce que c'est un débat
dans lequel il faut arriver à émerger et
bien pouvoir faire passer nos idées je
lui souhaite évidemment toute la
réussite qu'il mérite parce que c'est
quelqu'un de grande qualité donc je suis
très heureux que ce soit lui qui a été
désigné par notre parti pour mener cette
liste aux Européennes en juin prochain
mais effectivement comment peut-il faire
pour se démarquer entre la liste de la
majorité présidentielle et la liste du
rassemblement national qui est en tête
dans les sondages nous avons des valeurs
auxquelles nous avons jamais déroger et
que nous devons défendre dans cette
élection européenne et je crois que les
valeurs de la droite doivent être
défendu aujourd'hui c'est le PPE dont
nous faisons partie parti popula euré
qui est majoritaire en Europe qui je
l'espère le restera et donc il est bien
évident qu'en étant dans cette majorité
du PPE nous aurons euh davantage de de
poids et donc nous nous nous nous
sollicitons vivement évidemment les les
français pour comprendre que aujourd'hui
euh la la solution des républicains est
une bonne et la bonne solution pour les
élections européennes merci beaucoup à
Cédric Perin d'avoir été le sénateur du
jour merci à vous